lo que más me gusta de las actividades
de campeonato es que les presentan a los
estudiantes el concepto de mentalidad de
crecimiento de neuroplasticidad o el
hecho de que el cerebro crece y cambia y
también les enseña la importancia del
esfuerzo es muy útil para los maestros
señalar y reconocer a los estudiantes
cuando están esforzándose pero también
es muy importante no utilizar el
esfuerzo como premio de consolación no
decirles está bien que no hayas
aprendido nada porque te esforzaste
mucho la idea es recordarles a los
estudiantes todo el tiempo que al
esforzarse realmente están preparando su
cerebro para crecer están encendiendo
todos los motores en su cerebro y que
incluso cuando aún no dominen un
concepto en particular el esfuerzo
intelectual que están poniendo al final
va a rendir frutos pues están preparando
su cerebro para entender con el tiempo
el proceso de ese contenido y también es
importante no enfocarse sólo en el
esfuerzo
en la combinación de esfuerzo y el uso
de buenas estrategias esto con el fin de
llamar la atención al hecho de que si
están trabajando muy duro en algo bueno
quizá deban perseverar un poco más pero
si realmente les está costando mucho
trabajo puede ser más útil dar un paso
atrás y pensar si se puede utilizar otra
estrategia quizá hablar con alguien que
pueda ayudarles a pensar de otra forma
ese problema o este concepto en
particular para asegurarse de que el
esfuerzo que están invirtiendo realmente
esté sirviendo para aumentar esa
habilidad